Minor stimulants are things such as caffeine and energy drinks, whereas major
stimulants are drugs such as cocaine and methamphetamine. In general,
stimulants do what they word says. They stimulate. And they do so by activating
the sympathetic nervous system. You remember, our fight-or-flight nervous
system. Now in general, all stimulants produce similar effects, but they do so
to a different degree. For example, caffeine will increase energy, but nowhere
near the same level as cocaine or methamphetamine. The stimulants produce an
increase in energy, talkativeness, and motor behavior. In addition, they also
elevate mood and can produce feelings of power or confidence. In fact, it's
these powerful effects on feeling and mood that make the major stimulants such
as cocaine and methamphetamine drugs of abuse. These stimulants produce their
reinforcing effectiveness by activating the nucleus accumbens and the dopamine
reward pathway. Now it's important to remember that tolerance can develop to
some of the drug's effects, and I'm going to send it back to Lauren to talk
more about tolerance.